hello dad is it good sit right there
good morning John we were having dinner
the other night with this our dad and I
found out about a habit of yours when
you are what how old wasn't it wasn't a
habit I could stop anytime I wanted to
it was after-school ritual when I was
eight or nine or ten no long day on the
school bus come in to the kitchen get
out some white bread Wonder Bread and
put two or three teaspoons of sugar on
the bread and then just eat it
crunch crunch I spent a long time since
since you've done that well yeah do you
think that it's gonna be familiar if we
do this again oh I can feel the crunch
right now but I don't know that it's
gonna be a good thing well I really want
to try it we've got some classic white
bread this is pretty doughy gooey stuff
so make make it for me dad other people
do this where you just like take the
sugar and put it in your mouth it's a
kid do it cuz you can know cuz kids now
have actual candy don't know how I did
this I'm sure I didn't just like tap my
fingers so that's one spoonful I did it
alone okay my mother wasn't there my
brothers weren't there do you think you
were getting away with something nice it
was a snap I don't remember drinking a
lot of sodas and they're like you know
there's like a third sugar it's soda
bread that's different then you sort of
balanced the sugar on the bread he's not
nearly as thick as what I used to eat
well oh wow that's a lot gotta shake it
so it gets in the nooks and crannies
yeah I'm gonna do this yeah
three two one mmm crunch that's not bad
at all my god do I have to eat the whole
thing do you want to eat both thank good
you already ate a lot of it well come on
start eatin do I have to eat all day
he's like 90% done okay okay let's put
it down I also have another segment of
the video a bunch of people have said
nice things about my book but I don't
feel right reading them out loud my cell
I cut them out and put them on little
pieces of yeah paper board for my dad to
be led by an earnestly flawed bisexual
heroine with direction and commitment
issues sounds like all the young people
I know
coupled with an abundant generosity of
spirit this read is timely and sorely
needed highly recommended funny
thrilling an absolute blast to read I
knew Hank would be good at this but I
didn't know he would be this good on his
first try I think I would be less good
on my second try if that's any
consolation this is the book my team
self would have loved and my adult self
immediately obsessed over by turns
joyful devastating personal zeitgeist II
modern classic fast-paced and thoughtful
an absolutely remarkable thing blew me
away I read it it's a good book that's a
good blurb I'll put that in there I
wanted to eat a bunch of sugar bread -
excuse me spending this entire video
promoting things we're also going on
tour all the new tour information is up
now and Hank green calm they're
apparently selling pretty fast already
and then lastly mod Con is happening
again you are at pod con I was gonna
come again
what was your review of podcast I went
to pod con it was a good positive good
comment how combos great I'm Green is
coming and Mama green doesn't like to go
to big conference well this is mrs.
green catherine is coming - yeah so all
the mrs. Green's will be there and if
you want to learn more about pod con you
can go to pod can calm our crowdfunding
campaign is live now and we need people
to sign up so if you're not gonna see me
on tour maybe you could see me at pod
calm which will be January 19th
Antonio's in Seattle Washington have
even transported back to your youth I
was man I am with that crunch you know I
was making someone fun of you but this
isn't bad that's like a friggin Danish
yeah it makes it makes you think maybe I
should eat fewer danishes exactly Don
I'll see you on Tuesday I don't know how
that's gonna add it together but not I'm
not into four minutes my mentor said to
me the more you cut the better it gets
true that's the whole thesis of
vlogbrothers did you finish yours oh yes
[Laughter]